MALE SPEAKER: Startup times for
App Engine Java are pretty
high for my application,
around 30 seconds.
That is actually pretty high.
And Java Apps, in general, even
with reserved instances
that we feel are underutilized,
we're still
getting warm up requests.
Any advice?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so I
think, again, this is going to
be something that is going to
be covered quite extensively
in Google I/O. We have a talk,
Matt Stephenson actually is
going to be giving a talk
on autoscalling Java.
So that talk is likely to
cover much of that.
And Matt Stephenson also, with
one of our other guys from
Cloud Solution, Wally Yau, he
wrote an article that was
published on, again, the
App Engine's Developers
Documentation site for managing
optimization of
starting up spring
applications.
And often we find that the
spring applications really
take a longer time to start.
There's a lot of libraries
involved.
There is a lot of scanning of
classes and such that goes on
automatically with spring
when it starts up.
And that can lead to quite
long load times.
I think, as I suspect, this
is probably likely
to be a spring issue.
At the same time I mean it's
also the possibility that
you're loading libraries that
you may not need immediately.
And you may want to actually
look at lazy loading those.
Loading them in the background
as opposed to actually loading
them as your instance starts.
Anything you can do to minimize
the amount of time it
takes to start the applications
is good.
And really, I think that's the
key to handling things like
start up requests, things
that will cause new
instances of starts.
It's basically just to minimize
the time it takes to
load your application
initially.
Only load what you need, lazy
load and everything.
Don't load things you
don't need to load.
And also make sure if you're
using spring that you follow
the advice in the Google
[INAUDIBLE]
and in that particular document
on the website.
That will minimize your start up
times, and you won't be so
worried about start up requests
then when things
actually load a new instance,
because it won't
take so long to do.
MALE SPEAKER: Yep.
All very good advice.
So definitely check out
the Google I/O talk.
All the talks at I/O are
going to be recorded.
So we can check those out.
Talk is happening next week.
So that's a great resource.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's on
Wednesday, by the way.
Are they live streamed?
MALE SPEAKER: Some
of the talks are.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Some of the
talks are live streamed.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm not sure if
Matt's talk is live streamed.
You'll be able to catch
it pretty soon.
Maybe something just say a
little bit more in general
about App Engine Java especially
these spring apps
or applications that have these
big frameworks and long
loading times.
So one way to think about this
is the way that we've been
building application servers for
many years has been in an
environment where you would spin
up, say, five application
servers, and these would be big
servers that would sit on
a rack somewhere.
And they would take several
minutes to kind of boot up, do
all the memory checks, right?
Machine would load up.
It would load the application
server software.
Then it would load the specific
applications.
And that whole process could
take 10, 20 minutes sometimes.
But then those servers, they
would run for weeks or months
or however long they
needed to run.
And in that environment what
you actually want to do is
kind of do all the expensive
work up front when you're
loading the application, because
you know you're only
going to do that one time, and
then you're going to have long
lived servers,
App Engine tries to really kind
of fundamentally deal
with applications in
a different way.
When we want to scale up very
quickly to handle an increase
in traffic to your website, or
when we want to scale down
because there's a little bit
less traffic coming in, we
really need the ability to
quickly spin up new instances
of your application.
And then spin them back down
kind of at a moment's notice.
And so App Engine's kind of
optimized around apps that
have a very short
start up time.
Ideally, it's hundreds
of milliseconds.
Maybe it's a few seconds
on the outset.
When you start getting into like
30 second time frames,
that's really a whole
different ball park.
Now, if that's something you
want to do, and you want to
run spring applications, and
you say, I get a lot of
benefit out of that.
And why can't I just
run an App Engine?
You can.
We actually, I think a year ago
or so, we introduced some
extra knobs on the
admin console
specifically for these users.
What you'll need to do is go
into the admin console.
Make sure you enable billing,
because that exposes all the
knobs that we have.
And then go into your
application settings.
And there's a couple of settings
around min max idle
instances, min max pending
requests latency.
And those allow you to kind of
tune the cost performance of
your application.
So if you know you have long
loading requests, and you just
need to keep in a few extra
instances around to make sure
you can handle those spikes,
even though you have long
instances, you can
actually crank up
the min idle instances.
On the other hand, if you're a
fast starting app, and you're
very cost sensitive, there's
ways to turn
it the other direction.
We recommend everyone
start out with
the automatic settings.
But we do have some special
knobs for that.
And I'm sure Matt, in his talk,
will go into a lot more
detail than we did right here.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
definitely.
MALE SPEAKER: Specifically
around Java applications.
So that's definitely something
we care about.
And we'll have some
advice for you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
that's great.